Поставки "Газпрому" на європейський ринок
знизилися в першому кварталі поточного року на понад 24%.
Збут "блакитного палива" до Німеччини, за даними Федеральної митної служби Росії,
знизився за цей же період на 45%.
На окремих напрямках падіння газового експорту особливо драматичне.
Наприклад, за даними турецького енергетичного відомства,
в березні Туреччина імпортувала на 70% менше російського газу, ніж у минулому році.
Раніше американське видання The Wall Street Journal стверджувало, що
низка турецьких компаній заборгували "Газпрому" загалом
близько 2 мільярдів доларів через схеми "бери або плати".
За даними видання, сім приватних компаній торік
закупили у концерну менше 15% від домовлених обсягів газу.
"Газпром", вочевидь, не хоче йти на поступки і прощати просто так ці борги,
тому що ці турецькі компанії, ймовірно, брали газ,
але не у "Газпрому", розраховуючи, що з "Газпромом" можна буде домовитися.
До всього іншого державна Польська нафтова і газова компанія - PGNiG -
30 червня отрималавід "Газпрому" гроші, які переплатила за газ - 1,5 мільярда доларів.
Це не перший випадок для Газпрому. Першим випадком,
коли довелося споживачам вдаватися до послуг Віденського арбітражу, була Словаччина.
"Газпром" заплатив майже півтора мільярда доларів за ту ціну газу, яку він отримував до цього,
і вона була явно завищена, в чому переконалися арбітри.
Потім ми бачили, що довелося платити Україні майже 3 мільярди доларів.
Проблемою став і обвал цін на енергоносії,
однак і на цьому перелік проблем російського газового велетня не обмежується.
Раніше в ЗМІ активно поширювалася інформація, що "Газпром"
може перекрити поставки газу в Білорусь вже з 1 липня.
На цьому тлі експерти навіть говорили про загрозу нової газової війни,
а президент Білорусі Олександр Лукашенко заявляв про можливість купувати газ не тільки в Росії.
За його словами, на ринку йде боротьба за можливість постачати газ в республіку.
Експерти звертають увагу на політичне забарвлення паливної суперечки.
Тому що, в принципі, ще на початку року домовилися: добре,
ось за такою ціною 172 долари за тисячу кубометрів будемо постачати вам газ,
підписали угоду, домовилися про все, а потім білоруси подивилися:
о, а в Європі "Газпром" по скільки газ продає на своїх електронних майданчиках,
були випадки, коли по 56 доларів, 72 долари.
У Мінську сказали, а чи не можна нам теж якимось чином отримати європейські ціни.
Ще один важливий напрямок для Кремля - ​​Китай.
Наприкінці червня глава "Газпрому" Олексій Міллер заявив, що концерн
домовляється з Пекіном про збільшення поставок по газопроводу "Сила Сибіру" на 6 мільярдів кубометрів.
Однак, на думку низки експертів, з поставками в КНР не все так благополучно.
Мені китайці говорили ще 2-2,5 роки тому в Пекіні:
ми дивимося на російський газ як на запасний варіант.
Якщо через військово-політичну обстановку в Тихому океані
ми не зможемо отримувати зріджений газ в тих обсягах, які потрібні,
то доведеться звернутися до Росії і отримувати газ звідти.
Звісно, не можна забувати про ще один проєкт "Газпрому",
без якого не обходиться жодне обговорення перспектив концерну на енергетичному ринку.
Це "Північний потік-2", роботи з будівництва якого наразі заморожені.
США загрожують йому новим пакетом санкцій.
Паралельно в суді Дюссельдорфа на розгляді
перебуває апеляція компанії Nord Stream 2 AG на рішення
німецького Федерального агентства з мереж, яке відмовилося
звільняти "Північний потік -2" від дії Європейської газової директиви.
Майбутнє цього амбітного трубопроводу поки в підвішеному стані.
Хоча попри це в Німеччині триває будівництво сухопутного продовження магістралі.